there's a segment of the party who wants
to keep the Republicans in the past
jameelah salvia is the co-founder of the
now-defunct gay Republican group go
proud for years he was one of the most
prominent gay conservative activists in
America in his new book no hope why I
left the Republican Party and why you
should to lasalle via talks about how
the party's failure to adapt to
America's fast-moving evolution on
social issues led him to question as
partisan loyalty and ultimately embrace
political independence Jimmy thanks so
much for talking to us thanks a lot for
having me so the book is basically your
tell-all about why you went from being a
lifelong conservative and longtime GOP
activist to a dissident talk about the
moment that you decided to leave the
party one very highly publicized
controversy was when go proud was a
co-sponsor of CPAC the big conservative
conference we were boycotted by anti-gay
social conservatives and there was a
real effort over two years to get us
kicked out of CPAC eventually they were
successful then the presidential
campaign started in 2012 I was the most
high-profile gay person advocating for
Mitt Romney and that was torturous for
me the Republican Party's been hostile
to gays for a very long time so what
made the party tenable to you in the
first place what made you pick that to
you well I grew up in an Air Force
family grew up with a conservative
perspective there came a point about a
decade ago in 2004 when I knew the
Republican Party was on the wrong track
regarding issues relating to gays and so
I wanted to work with them while the
country was evolving to make sure that
they weren't left in the past and
ultimately while I made great progress
and we had some great successes
ultimately there's a segment of the
party who wants to keep the Republicans
in the past so it's just social issues
is that the main focus on the party
that's just it it's I came to see that
there's a segment of the right who just
aren't comfortable with people who
aren't like themselves and in our new
modern multicultural reality
that makes that coalition untenable for
most Americans so if the purpose of
political parties is to win elections
and you know all the ultimate prize is
the White House I just don't think that
that untenable coalition that is
unacceptable
to most Americans has the ability to win
the White House you talk about your
disgust for partisan politics but you
speak warmly in the book of both Ann
Coulter and the late Andrew Breitbart
both of them made their names on
incendiary rhetoric why is their
partisanship okay with you and others
aren't
I think in some cases and in particular
she did a lot to help me and to help gay
conservatives right I was on your
website go proud and there was a lot of
what does go proud a conservative gay
group and the real conservatives unlike
Log Cabin Republicans Andrew Breitbart
you mentioned he was a good friend of my
organization and mine and he did a lot
of great things to help gay
conservatives he was really smart with
his bomb-throwing
and I think that since he passed away a
lot of people amp up their divisive Ness
I mean there was an article on Breitbart
comm recently that referred to the
rainbow flag as a gay hate yeah I often
times ask myself what Andrew would think
of his company these days I think
they've gone off the rails and always
trying to force controversy and many
times we see where issues move from
being right versus left to right versus
wrong and we've seen that with race
we've seen it with gender now we've seen
it with sexual orientation too many on
the right tolerate those people who
don't their position has now become
wrong to most Americans and so if you're
always defending parts of your coalition
and defending their right to be wrong
then eventually everyone else thinks
that you are just as wrong as they are
in your book you talk about meetings
with certain Fox executives and you kind
of imply that they don't even believe
half the stuff I'm selling can you
talk a little bit about that well I
remember it was back in 2011 I believe
and I get this call and it's Roger Ailes
his assistant and a few days later I was
in his office and we were talking about
their coverage of gay people and gay
issues roger was very frank you know he
understood where the country was going
culturally and that the whole country
was evolving and was evolving very fast
but that their audience wasn't
throughout the course of the following
two years I had many conversations with
other executives at Fox News and one
thing that I came to learn is that they
program for the audience and they know
what gets ratings and so they give a
safe place for those people who are
wrong on issues to be wrong because
their audience wants to be validated
they refer to their audience as the OFW
G's which stands for which stands for
old fat white guys and showed me what
they really think of their business that
it's all business with them it's not
that they have a certain point of view
they understand the emotional triggers
that fire up their audience and so when
I was looking at you know my work within
the conservative movement and the
Republican Party it's very hard to help
move the dial and help them evolve
culturally
when you have their primary source of
news validating their opinions that are
based in the past you talked a little
bit about Mitt Romney it seems like
around the time of his presidential
candidacy is when you pretty much had
your heart broken for the last time
these days especially with the crop of
Republican candidates they've got people
are looking back to Mitt Romney is the
last civilized man to make it to the
front so tell me why you would disagree
oh my gosh the vote for president is an
emotional vote voters want a candidate
who they think sees things from their
perspective
the old adage who do you want to have a
beer with and
Romney is perhaps the worst candidate
for that you know he's this rich white
guy he's Mormon who doesn't drink and
he's culturally out of touch I mean
completely I mean he had no interest in
people helping him to appear to be
culturally connected go proud didn't
even have a position on gay marriage
we were the tea party gays we were the
perfect vehicle for the Romney campaign
to use to show that he is culturally
connected they flat-out denied sending a
surrogate to speak at our event at the
Republican convention we threw an event
in Tampa at his convention to herald our
support for him we had a thousand people
in the room and they couldn't even send
anybody to say thank you that was a
bridge too far with them we couldn't
appear publicly and after six months of
being the gay from MIT who was met with
a facepalm every time I was asked to
help I decided not to vote for him
you're pushing for non partisan politics
and the book is called no hope but do
you see any hope among the next
generation of Republicans in possibly
saving their party from itself I think
there are a whole lot of young
right-of-center people who care about
their country and are engaged and I
would just urge them to join me outside
of the political system we're a
right-of-center country we need to roll
back the size and scope of our
government and as long as you're playing
on a team that's consists of an
untenable coalition you're wasting your
time let's focus our efforts on making
our country better not just helping some
people be in charge thanks so much
Jimmy LaSalle via the co-founder of NGO
proud and the author of the new book no
hope why I left the Republican Party and
why you should too for recent TV I'm
Anthony Fischer